life was one of the best Starcraft 2
players to ever touch a mouse and
keyboard oh my god this certainly
control is so good from life he's
narrowly avoiding the banelings d voids
him yet again will any of them connect
no the Queen Falls and life oh my god is
playing this out spot-on he was dominant
he gets us around Elise wow they're
controlling realize what on earth are
you not human that for damn sure
he was adored
[Music]
and he was on top of the world that is
until he was convicted of match-fixing
and sentenced to 18 months in prison all
just 19 years old
life made a name for himself in early
2012 it's actually just gonna play the
shortest game ever GG life catches him
completely off Garcia generally
surprised and this attack was really
well thought out and white surplice
whole life managed to pull this off and
the build order here for hey Pro was a
woman strange GT paper working up later
spire really committing to his opponent
though had all the preparations in life
is too strong today he is certainly an
honor oh GG he takes down 5 opponents
life with an all-kill but life's early
wins were just him warming up at GSL
season 4 he showed the Starcraft
community what he was truly capable of
I'm setting big names like marine King
and Teja it's as if they're like bees
let the beat you you know maybe you have
you have to play defense against life
it's not
Wow god this is going to be his death
throes here this is the last of his
final flight boasted an 18 and 5 record
heading into the finals giving him a
shot at the Royal Road at his first GSL
the Royal Road is when a rookie player
wins a major tournament for the first
time they're eligible to compete it's an
incredibly difficult task that you have
ever achieved the life's opponent and
the grand finals was his toughest
challenge yet
[Applause]
[Music]
in a best-of-seven series the duo went
back and forth the new generation versus
the veteran talent trading mat for map
life's aggressive play won him to maps
early but MVP wasn't fazed and took the
next three like this
GJ realizes that in fact he's taking so
much damage and MVP has enough
and fbp said uh uh facing elimination
life went to maps back-to-back to bring
down MVP and become the first any
youngest player to walk the GSL royal
road and our champion
[Applause]
first royal roader receiving the Super
Bowl prior to life conventional zerg
play relied on big late-game armies with
units like brood Lords and investors
life went in the opposite direction
building cheap armies quickly and using
a fast and aggressive style of play to
catch his enemies off-guard
he revolutionized the game life was the
guy who was going to show you that the
new way to play surged in this more
advanced way where you're very active
your micros incredibly precise you're
everywhere on the map and you're always
trying to make things happen you're not
a passive player anymore you're an
aggressive player you're forcing the
action he really had a killer instinct
as a player that he would finish games
as soon as he would see the opportunity
to be able to do it rather than take the
risk of prolonging the game and maybe
along your player to come back the
opponent compact and his control was
just beyond anybody else's what he did
well circlings in particular was unheard
of and actually we haven't really seen
anybody do quite the same he has become
so that again after GSL season 4 life
was on a roll winning his first
tournaments outside of South Korea those
victories earned life roughly 82
thousand dollars and the wins kept
coming 90 well continue to hold on
there's a notice it behind the Hydra
about to be morphed in the mothership
core is gone the DTS are the last real
units that Naniwa has G
start a life yes the in Tights dream
masters New York City at comic-con
champions in fact fairly hanging on the
entrance the links spill in and there's
not much left that in fact can do and
Gigi boy is our Dreamhack Bucharest
champion can it may make all this is
incredibly tale Bailey's about some or
those three bay leaves could be huge
[Music]
between October 2012 and November 2014
life one 328 thousand dollars in prize
money alone money status and thousands
of adoring fans life was on top of the
[ __ ] world until he wasn't in October
2015 the Special Investigations Unit of
the channel on regional Prosecution
Service released a report detailing
match-fixing and Starcraft 2 the report
highlighted the arrests of mid tier
players Yoda Byung Byung and their coach
Gerrard
alongside four middlemen and two
financial backers they went into it and
they discovered like really a terrible
match-fixing ring a bunch of players
were caught on crime which would have
been like a fan favourite team and it
was particularly bad because he
discovered that the coach due to some
being a financial arrest he became like
the coach of team owner he became the
middleman between these people who want
to pay players matchsticks the community
reaction was vitriolic and KeSPA came
down on them hard banning them for life
but then Starcraft 2 s biggest star was
charged and convicted of mass spec sex
one of the two pro gamers arrested as
part of this investigation is 19 year
old life one of starcraft 2 s top 50
players with a number of achievements
under his belt the arrests
a former Blizzard world champion Lee
Lifesong hyung has been followed with an
indictment on January 29th 2016 life was
arrested and charged with match-fixing
during season 1 of the 2015 test become
lifeless find roughly $60,000 the
equivalent of what he was paid to throw
the games and he was given an 18-month
prison sentence when it came out it was
like I was really angry about it because
he had you know no reason to do it other
than that he could got himself in a very
bad situation in his life but was
gambling and all that but if it would
have been a little bit smarter he would
have been set pretty well in life as a
very very young
very successful player he served two
months before the sentence was suspended
and reduced to probation and if you're
thinking what the hell did wife set some
cruel precedent or something well no not
really
you see back in 2010 one of the greatest
old guard Starcraft players savior was
caught up in his own match-fixing
scandal that rocked the community he ten
other players and one coach were fined
thousands of dollars banned from ever
competing in Blizzard or casco events
and were painted jail sentences mana so
it was pretty bad just the fact that
like to to know that it happened to get
you I mean actually people suspected
that you know that one in a round of
arrests would have stamped it out so
when it went one in 2015 the crime
scandal happens like people are like
it's just it's hard being to know the
man like after four years later like not
much has changed like with what lessons
I've really been learned fundamentally
they're still add incentive to like for
these guys take money and think dives
let's be clear here match-fixing
sucks and life knew what he was doing
but well I didn't actually throw any
matches purportedly pthrough individual
games while still winning the series
outright we're not disputing the ban or
the fine because this is a crime and the
punishment has to be severe but
president seems like a little much in
this case because when the streams turn
off and the confetti is fallen we're
still talking about stadiums full of
computers and young adults who are prone
to making mistakes and does the
reputation of a game mean more than the
future of a 19 year old kid
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button